how did we get here why does it appear
that we're on the brink of a war in Asia
one that could involve nuclear weapons
north Korea has had nuclear weapons
capacity for at least 10 years now have
its recent advances been so dramatic and
significant to force the United States
to wage a preventive war no the crisis
we now find ourselves in has been
exaggerated and mishandled by the Trump
administration to a degree that is
deeply worrying and dangerous from the
start the White House has wanted to look
tough on North Korea in the early months
of Trump's presidency before they could
possibly have been a serious policy
review Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
warned that the era of strategic
patience with North Korea was over Trump
of course went much further this week
they will be met with fire fury and
frankly power the likes of which this
world has never seen before Trump has
made clear that the United States would
respond to North Korean nuclear threats
rhetoric with a massive military strike
possibly involving nuclear weapons is
this credible no the United States is
not going to launch a preventive nuclear
war in Asia empty threats and loose
rhetoric only cheapen American prestige
and power boxing in the administration
for the future so why do it because it's
Trump's basic mode of action for his
entire life Donald Trump has made
grandiose promises and ominous threats
and never delivered on either when he
was in business he frequently threatened
to sue news organizations but the last
time he apparently followed through was
in 1984 over 30 years ago in his
political life he has followed the same
strategy in 2011 he claimed he had
investigators who cannot believe what
they're finding about Barack Obama's
birth certificate and that he would soon
be revealing some interesting things he
had nothing during the campaign he vowed
that he would label China a currency
manipulator move the embassy in Israel
to Jerusalem make Mexico pay for a
border war in this
an investigation into Hillary Clinton so
far nada
after being elected he signaled to China
that he might recognize Taiwan within
weeks of taking office he folded when
the United States watched a Stalin
Soviet Union developed nuclear weapons
it was careful in its rhetoric when it
saw far more threatening leader Mao
Zedong pursuing nuclear weapons it was
even more cautious Mao insisted he had
no fear of nuclear war because China
would still have more than enough
survivors to defeat Western imperialists
and yet successive u.s. administration's
kept their cool the world is already
living with a nuclear North Korea it has
for a decade if that reality cannot be
reversed through negotiations and
diplomacy and sanctions the task will be
to develop a robust system of deterrence
the kind that kept the peace with
Stalin's Russia and Mao's China bluster
from the president can increase the
dangers of miscalculation I think
Americans should sleep well at night
have no concerns about this particular
rhetoric of the last few days said Rex
Tillerson on wetness day this was an
unusual perhaps unprecedented statement
the Secretary of State seems to have
been telling Americans and the world to
ignore the rhetoric not of the North
Korean dictator but of his own boss the
president of the United States it is
probably what Donald Trump's associates
have done from all his life they know
that the guiding mantra for Donald Trump
has been not the art of the deal
but the art of the bluff